vous prenez des cailloux tout âge vous
prenez les crachats et abandonnez vous
prenez un coup hélas ce moment-là vous
donnez un coup c'est l'effet tunnel
il est compréhensible actuellement il
n'est pas admissible
je suis policier depuis le 1er décembre
1990 le 1er décembre 1990 à 18 heures
jeux franchissait les portes de l'école
de police de sens
[Musique]
la police la vraie folie
c'est la police locaux la police qui va
intervenir à 6 heures du matin parce que
la voiture est mal garé une voiture
garée devant de votre sortie de garage
et vous devez à tout prix à les autres
rendez vous sinon vous allez perdre
votre boulot une femme qui se fait
battre par son mari il faut intervenir
le plus rapidement possible pour mettre
fin à l'infraction ci-après l' désirent
déposer plainte si on met de marion
garde à vue c'est des choses qui sont
accessoires utiles mais accessoires vous
avez mis farine infraction mais homme
vous dire ils n'ont pas que ça à faire
s'occuper de la délinquance routière
ils n'ont pas que ça à faire de ces pv
on pas dire de qu'ovide ils n'ont pas
que ça à faire de ma de travailler sur
le contrôle des magasins bien sûr qu'ils
le font c'est le job et le jambon le
fait mais franchement tournée dance
interne secteur sécurisé sortie d'école
sécurité des sorties de concert allait
sauver des gens c'est bien plus
important que savoir si robert ou marine
et ils ont bien leur assurance à leurs
jours
[Musique]
en fait il ya deux choses
iolo et la société supporte pas la
violence le moindre fait violence ou qui
sont la norme est illégal est
inadmissible on peut le voir notamment
sur les violences qu'on peut reprocher
des policiers sur beaucoup de violence
les gens se trompent
évidemment que la police fait usage de
violence pour interpeller quelqu'un
voulait interpeller quelqu'un qui a 200
g de shit il va pas se laisser faire
à titre personnel il ya effectivement
des scènes de violence que je bouge
pollet qui sont parfaitement légitimes
qui massacrent l'image que certains de
la police que certains essayent d'avoir
très souvent quand vous voyez on parle
maintien l'armée en coupe ce soit quand
il ya des policiers qui dérape et y en a
malheureusement c'est souvent par manque
d'encadrement
le policier pas là pour se venger et
c'est ça le problème mais c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué vous prenez qui a eu
toute la journée prenez les crachats et
un rendez vous prenez un coup et l'a
cependant là vous donnez un coup c'est
l'effet tunnel
il est compréhensible actuellement il
n'est pas admissible
comme c'est un policier on va diligenter
une enquête et il sera sanctionné bien
sûr qu'il sera sanctionné mais 0 10%
les interventions génère une saisine de
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale savez le parfois le peuple a
besoin de jeu et de sang là pour
l'instant le sens que plus facile à
sortir ce sont des policiers
[Musique]
est dégradée passe
ensuite parce qu'on a besoin d' aide
dont les rapports police population
je suis pas éducateur moi je suis un
policier chu
schématiquement un chef de guerre mais
l'expérience m'a appris et mon envie m'a
appris et discuter avec des avec de
jeunes ou moins jeunes dans les
quartiers à aider des associations bien
sûr mais on a besoin d'elle qui va
discuter avec une famille à la rue à 3
heures du matin il n'y a même pas de
service social la nuit vous savez je
dirais les rapports police population
soit pas un rapport commun entre un père
et est un enfant il ya un garçon trop
longtemps absent et quand ils vont
recommencer un petit peu d'autorité en
critique
les violences volontaires
2 dans les violences parce qu'on est on
a fait beaucoup de progrès et c'est très
bien sûr les devants les violences
conjugales
on en a quasiment tous les jours tous
les jours on a deux trois bien souvent
les maris mais pas qu'eux mais bien
souvent des hommes en garde à vue pour
des faits de violence
oui bien sûr bien sûr eu peur puis
difficile pour un commissaire c'est à
dire à ses hommes on recule on attend on
n'est pas en sécurité
épisode le plus marquant pour moi au
niveau de la peur s'est passé à
montgeron dans ma ville en ville où je
suis issue lorsque lors d'une
manifestation lycéenne je ne fais pas
attention je vais pour aider un de mes
collègues dans la manifestation et a
demandé un jeune par derrière le
fracasse une pierre au niveau du crâne
je suis tomber ko et vous savez ma
principale pour que j'ai eu c'est même
pas pour l'intégrité physique c'est que
un des gamins me pique mon arme
[Musique]
faut qu'on évolue avec ça mais le
mortier c'est notre grande crainte à
l'heure actuelle nous tire au visage et
qui s'interrompt se fait tirer dessus
malheureusement dans nos beaux lieux
assez souvent donc je vais avoir longé
par balle qui va aussi amortir le choc
je vais avoir un casque celui blindé qui
va me protéger mon visage mes cils
mortier et certains mortier en
particulier mortier allemands m'arrive
pleine face ça ça peut prendre feu et
dans ces cas-là on soumet en dessous
j'ai un t-shirt j'ai ma peau j'ai un
autre ça ces anciens flashball son appel
super pro oui la taille c'est la taille
des mortiers actuellement ça c'est la
taille de 40 46 ne tire actuellement
c'est ça il est actuellement les
mortiers sont cette année là c'est une
arme qu'on a pu on a pu en service 6-6
dans la police
[Musique]
je l'aurais pas frapper mais dans la
gestuelle voyez je le bloc si vous
prenez un saint vous voyez ça si vous
prenez comme ça dit qu'est ce qui va lui
faire le policier et non je fais ça pour
dire qu'est ce que tu as fait ce qu il
vient de laisser mon garde du corps
ils viennent le blessé mais vous voyez
la scène je met par terre allait visible
sur les réseaux sociaux
évidemment que c'est des paroles se
faire passer pour quelqu'un deux ans
pour quelqu'un raciste ou quoi que ce
soit c'est des cheveux par certains mais
c'est pas juste pour nous anton
commission plus difficile à avoir c'est
leur dire les gars on va continuer à y
aller dehors parce que la première
action l'heure actuelle 1 si vous
discutez pas en mode onze syndicats ou
coux o c vous savez quoi qu'ils se
débrouillent
la prochaine manifestation on reste là
remet le pied à terre
[Musique]
j'ai vécu une aventure humaine à calais
ou où je pense que bien sûr ça a changé
ma vie
quand vous rencontrez vous côtoyer des
jeunes gens ou du moins jeunes ont fait
3000 3500 km à pied que vous les voyez
sur la plage de calais en face il ya les
ouvre donc à peu près à 20 km à la nage
et que vous dites là bas mon boulot
c'est empêcher d'aller de l'autre côté
vous savez la question qui me posait à
l'époque c'est mais vous êtes sympas
pourquoi vous faites ça parce que c'est
mon job parce que c'est mon job c'est
une réponse simpliste qui était pas très
intelligent mais c'est mon job et le job
on la fin l'autre jour on l'a fait mais
l'aventuré humaine elle était
fantastique
la photo qui assure sur mon livre c'est
cette photo là qui a été prise alors que
je sais pas qui on l'apprenait c'est le
dernier migrants à la fin de la jungle
de calais il est syrien et c'est moi qui
ait réussi à lui trouver quelqu'un de sa
famille de façon à ce qu'il a laissé
passer pour partir en angleterre et la
grille derrière il ya le feu ça tire
dans tous les sens et que c'est dans ce
qui est connu des affrontements
et là il fait le tour et devant tout le
monde il prend le risque d'aller me
remercier après il prend le bus il vas y
prends le bus le channel et vend
l'angleterre est ma plus grande fierté
c'est que cg plus jamais entendu parler
[Musique]